This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的生活经历，进行一些在其他任何地方进行都不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人像穿着一套盔甲？它向世界释放出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就必须去使用它，听听...
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在I-Heart电台App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字TWO%，请在I-HeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们常说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
听闺蜜的话，相信我，宝贝，请在I-HeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是一个重大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we have
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。1984年是一个疯狂的年份。那确实是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。请在I-HeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时经历的最大变化、时刻和人生转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，因为我们...
course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Sometimes we have these episodes where I just go, I cannot believe we have never spoken about this before. We are like 300, maybe even 400 episodes in and we have never spoken about this topic. Today we're going to talk about friendship trios. We know from like countless studies and even so many episodes that we've done just how important our friends are, not just for our mental health, but for our physical longevity even. But what kind of happens? What changes when it's not just you and another best friend? And it's not a huge friendship group either. It's like this weird middle ground. Three people. The trio. That can get, and I know we've seen examples of this, like really complicated,
当然，我们要剖析二十岁的心理学。有时我们会录制这样一期节目，当时我就在想，真不敢相信我们以前从未讨论过这个话题。我们已经播了大约300期，甚至可能400期了，却从未谈论过这个主题。今天我们要聊聊三人闺蜜组合。从无数的研究甚至我们做过的众多节目中，我们深知朋友有多么重要，不仅对我们的心理健康，甚至对我们的生理长寿也很重要。但是会发生什么呢？当不只是你和另一个最好朋友，而不再是一个庞大的朋友圈时，会产生什么变化？这就像是一种奇怪的中间状态。三个人。三人行。这可能会变得——我知道我们都见过这样的例子——非常复杂，
not just because friendships are in themselves complicated, but because of this unique, platonic triangle dynamic. It can be a beautiful one. You know, you get to call two people your best friend. It can also get really, really messy. One person always kind of made me feel slightly left behind or distant or like the spare. There are moments of jealousy and resentment. And I guess it's really easy to see why. It's not just too. people navigating and bouncing their emotions between each other. Suddenly it's like almost a bit of a project to keep three different bonds going at once plus the entire friendship of the three of you at a whole. This is a perfect segue into a story that inspired this episode from a listener who
不仅因为友谊本身就很复杂，还因为这种独特的柏拉图式三角动态关系。这也可以是很美好的。你知道，你可以把两个人称作你最好的朋友。但它也可能会变得非常非常糟糕。其中一个人总是让我觉得有点被冷落、被疏远，或者像个多余的人。偶尔会有嫉妒和怨恨的情绪。我想原因其实很容易理解。这不只是两个人彼此交流和碰撞情绪。突然之间，维系三个不同的纽带，再加上你们三个人整体的友谊，几乎变成了一项复杂的工程。这是完美转折到一个故事的契机，该故事灵感来自一位听众发来的邮件，
wrote in with an experience exactly like this looking for some advice and I asked her, can I share this story for this episode and she said yes, please. So this was her message. I need some advice on whether it's time for me to leave my toxic friendship trio. Some context. Me and my best friends have known each other since we are eight years old. We're 24 now. We all went to college together and we've obviously had our ups and downs,
她写下了与此完全相同的经历并寻求一些建议，我问她，我可以在这期节目中分享这个故事吗？她说是的，拜托。所以这是她的留言。我需要一些建议，不知道现在是不是该离开我那个有毒的三人闺蜜组合了。提供一些背景信息。我和我最好的朋友从八岁就认识了。我们现在24岁。我们一起上了大学，当然也经历过起起落落，
but always remained thick friends throughout at all. We even dated best friends. My friends were bridesmaids at my sister's wedding. It has kind of been a fairy tale friendship situation in many respects. until last month. Last month, me and one of my friends had a small falling out after she showed up two hours late to my birthday dinner to go on a date with a guy, a second date, might I add. I expressed I was angry and then she proceeded to not talk to me for three days, but did speak to our other friend. We semi-made up, but she didn't exactly apologize and then flash forward to
但在这一切中始终是非常要好的朋友。我们甚至和对方最好的朋友约过会。我的朋友是我姐姐婚礼上的伴侣。在许多方面，这可以说是一个童话般的友谊故事。直到上个月。上个月，我和其中一个朋友闹了一点小别扭，因为她为了去跟一个男的约会——顺便提一下，这还是第二次约会——在我的生日晚宴上迟到了两个小时。我表达了我的愤怒，然后她接连三天不跟我说话，但却和我们的另一个朋友聊天。我们勉强言归于好，但她并没有真正道歉，接着快进到...
last weekend. I call up the girls to see what their Saturday plans are and the friend who remained neutral, tells me that they are on a trip together with two of our other friends in New York City, and they had simply forgotten to tell me. I was devastated. We do literally everything together, and they know that going to New York was a dream of mine since even before we met. They said they made the plans in the three days me and my other friend were fighting. I hate to admit it, but I lost my call, and we haven't spoken since. I can tell I've been blocked from seeing their Instagram stories and I'm feeling so lost, angry, devastated and hurt. Please, any advice, am I in the wrong or how do I salvage this French? I think this dynamic is the perfect example of what we're
上周末。我打电话给这几个女孩，问她们周六有什么安排，那个保持中立的朋友告诉我，她们正和纽约的另外两个朋友一起在那儿旅行，而她们竟然忘了告诉我。我崩溃了。我们真的是形影不离，她们也知道去纽约是我从我们认识之前就有的梦想。她们说，这个计划是在我和另一个朋友吵架的那三天里做出的。我讨厌承认这一点，但我当时失控了，我们自那以后就没再说过话。我能看出我的Instagram快拍已经被她们屏蔽了，我感到非常迷茫、愤怒、崩溃和受伤。求求大家给点建议，是我做错了，还是我该如何挽救这段友谊？我认为这种动态完美体现了我们今天要...
going to talk about today. And I think to give this listener a little bit of advice to begin with, like your reaction to both those situations of firstly your friend not showing up to dinner and then this trip, like, that's fair to me. The exclusion, like, honestly, at this point feels deliberate, especially since you said you'd made up in the meantime. You said you'd been talking to them in the meantime. And you were the one who was originally offended, or I guess wronged. I think it's also hard because listening to that, like your friend saying, we just forgot to tell you, how can you forget to tell someone, let alone your best friend that you're on a plane to their dream city without them when you otherwise talk like every single day? I
讨论的话题。我想先给这位听众一些建议，你对这两种情况的反应——首先是你的朋友没有出席晚宴，然后是这次旅行——在我看来，这很合情合理。说实话，这种排挤在此时此刻感觉是故意的，特别是考虑到你之前说过你们已经和好了。你说过在这期间你们一直有交流。而且你本来才是那个被冒犯、或者说被亏待的人。我觉得这也让人很难受，听到这些，你的朋友竟然说“我们只是忘了告诉你”，怎么可能忘记告诉一个人，更不用说你最好的朋友了，你在准备去她们梦想中的城市却不带她的时候，而你们平时每天都聊天。我...
think your frustration is totally justified and you need to probably seriously consider what kind of apology you want, that you need, that you deserve and whether you are willing to be the one who instigates that and reaches out or who waits. And I definitely think that at the very bare minimum, you need to send like a full, kind of dear John, like, hard on your sleeve message of like, I'm really hurt. And yes, my reaction may not have been neat and tidy, but it's because, because of how deeply I feel about you guys and about our bond and our friendship and also about the situation. I do feel like, you know, you need a proper apology. And can those people give you that? We're going to talk through, we're going to talk through that in this episode. Like,
觉得你的沮丧完全是合情合理的，你可能需要认真考虑一下你需要什么样的道歉，你所需要的、你应得的道歉，以及你是否愿意成为主动挑起话题并伸出援手或等待的那个人。我绝对认为，最起码，你需要发一条全面、真诚、掏心掏肺的信息，表达类似“我真的很受伤，是的，我的反应可能不够得体和冷静，但那是因为我对你们、对我们的纽带、对我们的友谊以及对这件事有着深深的在乎”。我觉得，你知道，你确实需要一个像样的道歉。这些人能给你吗？我们将在本节目录制中探讨、我们会讨论这个，就像...
that is my most basic in, like very, very minor advice to you. But I think the concepts in the psychology we're going to discuss as we go further into this episode are probably going to answer. this question for you. Are you going to be able to move forward? What is the dynamic of the friendship so far or as it is now and is it worth salvaging? We're going to discuss what it really means to be in a friendship trio, the role of the third wheel, how people often choose a specific role in a friendship trio and how those roles evolve over time and most importantly, how to avoid and had a deal with conflict when it inevitably comes up. So without further ado, let's get into it.
这只是我对你非常非常基础的小建议。但我认为，随着我们深入这期节目所要讨论的概念和心理学，可能会为你解答这个问题。你还能继续前行吗？目前或现在的友谊动态是怎样的，它还值得挽救吗？我们将讨论身处三人闺蜜组合的真正含义、电灯泡的角色、人们如何在三人组中选择特定角色以及这些角色随时间如何演变，最重要的是，如何在冲突不可避免出现时避免和处理它。废话不多说，让我们切入正题。
Honestly, friendship trios, I think they're pretty special. And I know that probably doesn't sound honest given the story we just heard. But when we look at the pros just for a second, you know, you basically get two best friends. It works really nicely on a practical level. Like if one friend is burnt out or if one friend is busy or going through it, there's double the support, but also double the options, double like the people to hang out with. Arguably, it's more fun. There's more personality, strengths, perspectives, more things to kind of contribute to your worldview.
说实话，三人闺蜜组合，我认为它们相当特别。我知道考虑到刚才听到的故事，这话听起来可能不太真诚。但如果我们暂且只看它的优点，你知道，你基本上拥有了两个最好的朋友。它在实际层面上运作得非常好。比如如果一个朋友精疲力竭，或者一个朋友很忙或正经历低谷，支持就会加倍，选择也会加倍，一起出去玩的人也加倍。可以说，它更有趣。有更多的个性、优势、视角，有更多可以为你的世界观做贡献的东西。
The in-jokes are also like arguably a lot better as well because there's more shared. And something I don't hear people talk about a lot is there's something uniquely affirming about watching your two best friends love each other the way that you love them. You know, it's one thing to know that you think somebody else is wonderful. And it's another thing to see that mirrored back by someone else you also deeply care about. So they do have the potential to be these amazing ecosystems of friendship. But I think they are sabotaged by a few basic things. I will say most of the psychological research on close friendships or close relationships that you will come across
内部笑话也可以说好得多，因为有更多共同的经历。还有一点我很少听到人们谈论，那就是，看着你最好的朋友像你爱她们那样彼此相爱，有一种独特而确信的美妙感。你知道，一方面你认为某人很棒是一回事，而看到你同样深切关怀的另一个人也投射出同样的喜爱，则是另一回事。因此，它们确实有潜力成为这种奇妙的友谊生态系统。但我认为它们会被一些基本因素所破坏。我得说，你将遇到的大多数关于亲密友谊或亲密关系心理学的研究，
is about diads, so pairs of people, best friends, romantic partners, you and one other. The sociologist George Simmel in the early 1900s, he was actually one of the first to say, like, hang on, what about a triad? What about a group of three? That isn't the same dynamic as a dyad plus an extra person thrown in there. The relationship behaves very different. because there are three people. And Simmel focused a lot on how the exact number of people within a relationship and a friendship just completely changes the dynamic of the relationship itself in a really unique way, like a chemical reaction. In a dyad, you know, this is the most intimate kind of relationship or friendship you can have. It's also the most fragile. You know, if one person walks away,
都是关于二元关系的，也就是两个人、最好的朋友、浪漫伴侣，你和其他一个人。社会学家乔治·齐美尔在20世纪初，实际上是第一批提出“等等，三人组合怎么样？三个人的群体呢？”的人。这与“二元关系再加上额外一个人”的动态并不相同。由于有三个人，这种关系的行为表现截然不同。齐美尔非常关注关系和友谊中的具体人数如何以一种非常独特的方式彻底改变关系本身的动态，就像化学反应一样。在二元关系中，你知道，这是你能拥有的最亲密的友谊。它也是最脆弱的。你知道，如果其中一个人抽身离去，
the relationship simply ceases to exist. You know, it is reliant on. both of you choosing to be in the friendship and to show up and to make it work, all the attention, all the conflicts, the repair, the reassurance moves directly between the two of you. So there's kind of nowhere to hide. There's no buffer. In a dyad also there is no majority. Like it's just two individuals who need to work things out as people. In a triad, however, a group of three, the group can actually survive the partial withdrawal of one member, like the relationship. between any two people is supported by the third person but can exist by itself. And this makes the entire group kind of stable and supposedly according to the research
这种关系就会不复存在。你知道，它依赖于你们两个人都选择留在友谊中、共同维系并努力让它运转，所有的注意力、所有的冲突、修复和安抚都直接发生在你们两个人之间。所以某种程度上无处可藏。没有缓冲。而且在二元关系中也没有多数派。这仅仅是两个人作为个体需要去解决问题。然而，在三人组合中，也就是三人组里，即使其中一个成员部分退出，这个群体实际上也能存活下来，比如任何两个人之间的关系，
a lot harder to break. You know, if two friends argue the third person can step in and be a mediator or if one person leaves the remaining two can continue the group. Social network researchers, particularly two researchers, Kenneth Goh and David Crackhart, they explore this with their idea of semilian ties and this is basically a close social tie that is embedded completely within a three person network we form a similian tie when two people have a strong and mutual relationship with each other and they also have a strong and mutual relationship with a third person who they have in common what comes out of that is actually four relationships not just one
虽然得到了第三人的支持，但也能独立存在。这使得整个群体在某种程度上保持稳定，并且据研究表明，
when you have two people in a relationship, you have one relationship. When you have three people in a friendship, you actually have four. So you might be very close to friend A, who is friends with friend B, who then becomes your friend, your C. This creates an A, B, B, C and C a relationship, but also an A, B, C relationship. Within one small group, four relationships for three people and for one larger relationship. and that's incredibly complex. Something interesting that actually occurs in friendship trios is that every member typically takes on their own unique role. I think there are three main roles in every friendship trio.
当你有两个人在恋爱中时，你拥有一段关系。当你有三个人在友谊中时，你实际上拥有四段关系。所以你可能与A朋友非常亲密，而A又与B是朋友，B随后又成了你的朋友，也就是C。这就产生了A-B、B-C和C-A的关系，同时也产生了A-B-C的关系。在一个小群体中，三个人却有四种关系，还有一种更大的关系，这极其复杂。有趣的是，在三人闺蜜组合中通常会出现的情况是，每个成员通常都会扮演自己独特的角色。我认为每个三人组中都有三个主要角色。
This isn't necessarily scientific, it's just something I've noticed by talking to people in my own life and with my researcher. The first is the bridge builder. Every single friendship trio has an organizer, has the center of command. They have this one person whose kind of calendar is like the guiding force of the friendship. They start the group chats. They remember the birthdays. They buy the football tickets. They book dinner.
这不一定是科学的，这只是我通过与自己生活中的人以及我的研究人员交谈所注意到的一些现象。第一个是桥梁建造者。每一个三人闺蜜组合都有一个组织者，也就是指挥中心。她们有这样一个人，其日程安排成了友谊的指导力量。她们发起群聊。她们记得生日。她们购买球票。她们预订晚餐。
They tend to do a lot of like the practical maintenance that keeps these really intimate ties active and sustained. Then there is the emotional anchor. This is the person who everyone seems to turn to when things are tricky. They are very emotive. They're a deep feeler. they're an advice giver. They also often end up being the mediator, the group mediator. I've noticed that the one who manages the emotions of the group
她们往往承担了很多实际的维护工作，使这些极其亲密的纽带保持活跃和持久。然后是情感锚点。这是当事情变得棘手时，每个人似乎都会求助的人。她们极具情感。她们是深切感受者。她们是提供建议的人。她们往往最终也成为调解员，即群体的调解员。我注意到，那个管理群体情绪的人，
is normally the one that's most likely to fall between the other two parties and is most likely to have to really deal with other people snarking about the other person and dealing with the other people venting about the other person in the group. they might not do a lot of the practical load, they do a lot of the emotional load. So there's upsides and downsides with each role. The third role I often see is what I call the wild card or the energy bringer. These are the people that are just essentially the chaos. Like they always have an outrageous story.
通常是最有可能夹在另外两方之间的人，也是最有可能不得不真正处理其他人对另一个人的刻薄言论、以及处理其他人在群体中对另一个人的抱怨的人。她们可能没有承担很多实际的琐事，但她们承担了大量的情感琐事。所以每个角色都有利有弊。我经常看到的第三个角色是我所说的百搭牌或活力带来者。这些人基本上就是混乱的源头。她们总是有离奇的故事。
They always make the last minute plans. They always have the unhinged voice notes. they might be less practically consistent, less emotionally consistent, but they are a source of what I would say is a huge amount of the group's fun, spontaneity, maybe even entertainment. Now, of course, these roles can overlap. The organizer might also be the emotional anchor. The wild card might also be the bridge builder or the organizer. In a healthy trio, these roles are actually shared around. So there isn't one person doing all. the emotional work all the time or all the planning all the time but we tend to kind of fall into if you're in a friendship trio one of these three groups and this dynamic can explain why trios can actually feel so comforting when they are working because you know everybody is kind of playing their part
她们总是临时起意做计划。她们总是发些语不惊人死不休的语音消息。她们在实际层面上可能不那么一致，在情感层面上也不那么一致，但我可以说她们是群体乐趣、即兴发挥甚至娱乐的重要来源。当然，这些角色可以重叠。组织者也可能是情感锚点。百搭牌也可能是桥梁建造者或组织者。在一个健康的组合中，这些角色其实是轮流承担的。所以不会总是一个人承担所有
it also kind of explains why small changes can feel really impactful because you know this entire social equilibrium will start to feel imbalanced if one person is angry or frustrated and stops playing their role. You know, if the planner suddenly stops planning, things are going to fall apart. If the energy giver gives too much chaos, everybody else is going to be frustrated.
的情感工作或所有的规划工作，但如果你身处一个三人闺蜜组合，我们往往会落入这三类人之一，这种动态可以解释为什么当三人组运转良好时会让人感到如此舒心，因为你知道每个人都在扮演自己的角色，
If the emotional anchor feels exhausted and doesn't feel supported themselves, they're going to stop wanting to be somebody that the other people can come to. The hardest part and the thing I think damages friendship trios the most is that dynamic when a minor like frustration emerges and it starts to impact how every single member starts to see each other. Specifically when two people start to hang out without a third. Like the story we heard at the beginning, this is like the thing that I think destroys most friendship trios. That's where the feeling of being the third.
如果情感支柱感到筋疲力尽，自己也得不到支持，他们就会不再想成为其他人可以依靠的对象。最难的部分，也是我认为对三人友谊伤害最大的，是当那种微小的挫折感出现时，它开始影响每个成员看待彼此的方式。特别是当其中两个人开始抛下第三个人单独出去玩时。就像我们在开头听到的故事一样，这就像我认为会摧毁大多数三人友谊的事情。这就是那种作为第三者的感觉。
third wheel starts to creep in. And this is like make or break. This is when I think we see them collapse. And I'm going to explain exactly why. Stick around to hear about it. We'll be right back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
第三者开始潜入。这就像是成败的关键。这就是我认为我们看到它们瓦解的时候。我将详细解释原因。留下来听听。我们休息一下，马上回来。2%。这是有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。这就是 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方的 T-W-O-Persent。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield and in this new season of the Girlfriends Oh my God, this is the same man A group of women discover They've all dated the same prolific con artist
你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女友》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现，她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。
I felt like I got hit by a truck I thought how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care So they take matters into their own hands I said oh hell no I vowed I will be his last target He's gonna get what he deserves Listen to the Girlfriends
我觉得自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以他们采取了私刑。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《女友》
Trust me babe on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay.
相信我，宝贝，在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击莉尔·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们都会挑选这里的内容，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特的节目，大谈 80 年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，但只是为了让大家知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们第二次讨论快克。所以我开始看出有一条贯穿始终的线索。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。欢迎来到我的新播客《The Hard Way》，我是您的主持人，也是您最喜欢的治疗师，
Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough.
基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、赖辛·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算够了。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得作为一个好人很重要，而你却在这里？你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同信任级别。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. Third wheel, the term third wheel. It's honestly such a brutal phrase, but it captures a feeling I think most people recognize. It is this sense of being there, but not actually feeling wanted, not feeling needed in a situation.
我希望你真正地成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索 Learn the Hardway，立即收听。第三者，第三者这个词。老实说，这是一个非常残忍的短语，但它捕捉到了我认为大多数人都能识别的感觉。这是一种在那里，但实际上并没有被需要的感觉，在某种情况下感觉不到自己被需要。
Like the third wheel of a bike, like we all know the. bike can function just with two. The third wheel knows the bike, doesn't need it. What we're really describing though is social ostracism, that feeling of being ignored, excluded, or kind of sidelined out of a social group. There has been actual research on what this does to us psychologically, mainly by one American researcher called Kipling Williams. He and his colleagues basically created this experimental condition called Cyberball. It's become very well known. This is what Cyberball is.
就像自行车的第三个轮子，我们都知道自行车只有两个轮子也能运转。第三个轮子知道自行车并不需要它。但我们真正描述的是社会排斥，那种被忽视、被排斥或被边缘化出社交圈的感觉。关于这对我们的心理有什么影响，已经有了实际的研究，主要由一位名叫吉普林·威廉姆斯的美国研究人员进行。他和他的同事基本上创造了一种名为 Cyberball 的实验条件。这已经变得非常有名。这就是 Cyberball。
It's an experiment or experimental condition where participants are put into a group and they're told to throw the ball back and forth with two or three other people. either online or in person. They could be in a room. They could also be doing it as like a video game. At first, they toss it to you and you toss it back to them and everybody's getting a bit of the ball. Then in this experimental condition, without explanation, all the other players just stopped throwing to you. The other two people, the other three people, what you don't know is that they're imposters. The game carries on. You are never thrown the ball again. like even talking about that feels like a school sports nightmare.
这是一个实验或实验条件，参与者被分成一个小组，并被告知与另外两三个人来回传球。无论是在线还是线下。他们可以在一个房间里。他们也可以把它当作电子游戏来做。起初，他们把它扔给你，你把它扔回给他们，每个人都能碰到一点球。然后在这个实验条件下，没有任何解释，所有其他玩家都停止向你扔球。另外两个人，另外三个人，你不知道的是他们是冒名顶替者。游戏继续进行。你再也没有接到过球。光是谈论这个就感觉像是一场学校运动噩梦。
But this study is really important in seeing the effects of being left out. And there was a meta-analysis of, I think, like 120 specific cyberball studies. I think there was like 12,000 participants in these studies overall, which found that even this small artificial exclusion created a really large mental effect. participants felt panicked, they got angry, they started crying, they got confused, sometimes they even reported like literal physical pain. And this effect, this like deeply psychological effect, this happens even though there was no big drama, nobody was hurt, there was no insults, just quietly being left out was enough to have a significant impact on these people. Let's bring that back to the trio, to our friend at the beginning of the episode. If this reaction in this cyberball game happens with strangers who you don't know at all,
但这项研究对于观察被冷落的影响非常重要。有一项关于我认为是 120 项具体的 cyberball 研究的元分析。我认为这些研究总共有大约 12,000 名参与者，结果发现，即使是这种微小的、人为的排斥也会产生非常大的心理影响。参与者感到恐慌、愤怒、开始哭泣、感到困惑，有时甚至报告有字面意义上的身体疼痛。这种影响，这种深刻的心理影响，即使没有大的戏剧性冲突，没有人受伤，没有侮辱，也会发生，仅仅是被悄悄冷落就足以对这些人产生重大影响。让我们回到三人组，回到本集开头的朋友。如果在 cyberball 游戏中的这种反应发生在完全不认识的陌生人身上，
and who wonder you're feeling so upset when it's your best friends, and they metaphorically stop passing the ball to you. The initial pain of exclusion, like, that's just the first layer, right? The second layer is the self-interrogation that comes with that. We could also call this like social-specific rumination, but it's when you've been excluded and then you start to look for an explanation within your own behavior. So you start to replay conversations, you blame yourself, you're scanning all your memories for what went wrong, you're hyper-analizing your behavior. From an evolutionary standpoint, this might make perfect sense, even though it's really frustrating. You basically want to know where you went wrong and how you can fix it.
而当你最好的朋友隐喻地停止把球传给你时，你却想知道为什么你感觉如此难过。排斥的最初痛苦，这只是第一层，对吧？第二层是随之而来的自我盘问。我们也可以称之为社交特定反刍，但这是当你被排斥时，然后你开始在自己的行为中寻找解释。所以你开始重播对话，你责怪自己，你在扫描所有的记忆，看哪里出了问题，你对自己的行为进行过度分析。从进化的角度来看，这完全说得通，尽管这真的很令人沮丧。你基本上想知道你在哪里做错了以及如何纠正它。
For most of human history, your survival depended on being part of a small group of food, for protection, childcare, information. Being socially excluded meant you would have less access to those resources, less protection and a higher chance of literally dying. So it makes sense for natural selection to kind of build a brain that is hypersensitive to any signs of rejection, especially in a group and even long before actual abandonment happens. In the 1995 paper, it's titled Need to Belong, it's one of our essential readings, the authors argue that belonging and feeling seen and included is just as fundamental as shelter, as security, as warmth. A lack of belonging is linked to literal health problems, increased risk of getting dementia,
在人类历史的大部分时间里，你的生存取决于成为一个小群体的一部分，以获取食物、保护、育儿、信息。被社会排斥意味着你获得这些资源的渠道减少，保护减少，并且真正死亡的几率更高。因此，自然选择建立一个对任何拒绝迹象都高度敏感的大脑是在情理之中的，尤其是在群体中，甚至在实际抛弃发生很久之前。在 1995 年的一篇论文中，题为《归属需要》，它是我们的基本读物之一，作者认为，归属感、被看到和被包容的感觉与住所、安全、温暖一样基础。缺乏归属感与真正的健康问题、患痴呆症的风险增加有关，
increased risk of getting sick more often, virus susceptibility. So researchers later took this further and they argued that social exclusion is processed using the same systems in our brain that handle physical pain. Basically, evolution has co-opted the pain system to ensure that we pay attention to threats to our sense of belonging and to being excluded. Feeling like the third wheel and having a deeply painful reaction to that is not stupid. you are not overreacting. There is scientific evidence here that this is like, this sucks.
生病更频繁的风险增加，对病毒的易感性增加。因此，研究人员后来将这一点推进了一步，他们认为社会排斥的处理使用的是我们大脑中处理身体疼痛的相同系统。基本上，进化已经借用了疼痛系统，以确保我们关注对我们归属感和被排斥感的威胁。感觉自己像个第三者，并对此产生深深的痛苦反应，这并不愚蠢。你没有小题大做。这里有科学证据表明，这真的很糟糕。
Like, biologically, your body is primed to push back against this. And it really does, I like, it hurts us on a physical level. I think it gets even more complicated with three people rather than with the big group, because you now have the minimum number you need for alliances. In conflict situations, there is always. always going to be an odd one out. Or when people are disagreeing, there's always going to be somebody who's left out. You can't split three evenly. Simple maths. Either the group splits three ways or more often two pair off. And this is when the fact that there are three of you and there
从生物学角度来说，你的身体已经准备好抵制这种反应。它确实如此，我喜欢，它在生理层面上伤害了我们。我认为三个人比大群体更复杂，因为你现在拥有了结盟所需的最小数量。在冲突情况下，总会有一个落单的人。或者当人们意见不一致时，总会有人被冷落。你无法将三个人平分。简单的数学。要么小组分成三路，要么更常见的是两个人结成一对。这就是你们有三个人，而且存在
is an quote unquote spare or an extra bonus member at any given time. That is when this becomes a deeper unraveling for dynamics like this. There is a 2021 paper literally called friendship jealousy, tools for maintaining friendships in the face of third party threats that was published in, I think it was the journal of, it must have been the journal of social psychology. And what this paper shows so well is how when there is a third person, when you can see the threat of you being replaced, you act differently. Across 11 studies, researchers found that often friendship jealousy is uniquely triggered,
在任何特定时间，都有一个所谓的“多余的”或“额外的”奖励成员。这就是为什么这会演变成对这种动态的更深层的解体。有一篇 2021 年的论文，字面意思是《友谊嫉妒：面对第三方威胁时维持友谊的工具》，发表在，我想是《社会心理学杂志》上。这篇论文很好地展示了当有第三个人时，当你能看到你被取代的威胁时，你的行为会有所不同。在 11 项研究中，研究人员发现，通常友谊嫉妒是独特地被触发的，
not just by the idea that your friend might not like you anymore or could be taken away, but by third-party threats. So not just the idea of losing your friend, but losing them to someone else is more painful. And it makes us especially sensitive to cues of being replaced by the third person in the friendship. Because we can see this person. And we can literally, we know that this person is a nice person. We know that these people have a good bond. It's very easy for us to imagine them existing and going on without us.
不仅仅是因为你的朋友可能不再喜欢你或可能被夺走的想法，而是由于第三方的威胁。因此，不仅仅是失去朋友的想法，而是把他们失去给别人会更痛苦。这使我们对友谊中被第三者取代的线索格外敏感。因为我们可以看到这个人。我们可以字面意义上，我们知道这个人是个好人。我们知道这些人有着良好的纽带。我们很容易想象他们存在并继续没有我们的生活。
Friendship trios, they just make this so apparent. And so there is this additional level of competition around who is getting the most contact time, who is getting the most enthusiasm, who is everybody hanging out with more or less that kind of lingers. and it motivates what we call friendship guarding behaviors, these efforts to protect or keep the friendship between you and the one other person safe when you perceive that the other person, the third person is trying to take them from you. And how this manifests is, again, back to those behaviors. Suddenly that you're in, now that you're insecure,
三人友谊让这一点变得如此明显。因此，围绕谁获得最多的接触时间、谁获得最多的热情、大家跟谁在一起玩得更多或更少，存在着额外的竞争层面，这种竞争会挥之不去。它激发了我们所谓的友谊守护行为，这些努力是为了保护或保持你与另一个人之间的友谊安全，当你察觉到另一个人，即第三个人正试图把他们从你身边夺走时。这种表现形式，再次回到那些行为。突然之间你加入了，现在你感到不安全了，
you stop telling the other person about your plans, you stop including them, you stop talking to them. Even though you know what's wrong, even though you love them, when you feel a sense of threat, sometimes it's just how we naturally behave. And underneath all of this is this like quieter, I think running calculation about fairness. Here is where I'm going to introduce one final framework here to show why friendship traitors can be so difficult. It is called the equity framework of relationships.
你不再告诉另一个人你的计划，你不再包容他们，你不再和他们说话。即使你知道哪里错了，即使你爱他们，当你感到受到威胁时，有时这只是我们自然的行为方式。这一切的背后是一种更安静的、我认为是关于公平的持续计算。在这里，我要引入最后一个框架，以说明为什么三人友谊会如此困难。它被称为关系的公平框架。
This framework was developed by the researchers Elaine Hatfield and Susan Spretcher, and they suggested that in close relationships, we care a lot about the balance between what we give, so time, care, love, money even, and what we get, support, appreciation, reliability, gratitude, back, especially when there are other people involved in that same relationship. When that balance feels off, so when you feel you're not getting the same amount as that person who's not getting the same amount as this person who's giving that person more, this ultimately leads to that fear about, again, being replaced. It leads to relationship guarding behaviors. It leads to ostracism. That is what contributes to friendship breakdown. It's all interconnected. And it all comes back to this deep human desire. We want to feel important. We want to feel seen. We want to feel like we matter in relationships.
这个框架是由研究人员伊莱恩·哈特菲尔德（Elaine Hatfield）和苏珊·斯普雷彻（Susan Sprecher）提出的，他们提出在亲密关系中，我们非常关心我们付出（如时间、关怀、爱甚至金钱）与我们得到（支持、赞赏、可靠性、感激）之间的平衡，尤其是当同一关系中涉及其他人时。当这种平衡感觉不对劲时——当你觉得你得到的没有那个拿不到同样数量的人多，或者没有那个给那个人更多的人多——这最终会导致对再次被取代的恐惧。它会导致关系守护行为。它会导致排斥。这就是导致友谊破裂的原因。这一切都是相互关联的。这一切都归结为这种深刻的人类欲望。我们希望感到重要。我们希望被看到。我们希望在关系中觉得我们很重要。
Is that just harder when you have a friendship trio? Is it just impossible to ever equally balance that? Just because of the nature or maybe the number of the friendship. Is that the outcome here? Like, do we just need to kill off the friendship trio? Do we just, like, not have social technology yet to have, have friendship trias. Personally, I actually don't think so. I know I've been quite pessimistic. I don't think so. I want to be optimistic here. Myself here, like, I'm in a really healthy,
当你拥有一个三人友谊时，这会更难吗？难道永远不可能平等地平衡这一点吗？仅仅因为友谊的性质或者可能是友谊的人数。这就是结果吗？就像，我们只需要终结三人友谊吗？我们只是，比如说，还没有社交技术来拥有三人友谊吗？就个人而言，我其实不这么认为。我知道我一直很悲观。我不这么认为。我想在这里保持乐观。我自己，就像，我身处一段非常健康的、
fun, fulfilling friendship trier. I have been for like almost four years. So I want to believe that it's possible. But I think some of the reasons I do think it works come down to how that friendship operates and what I've kind of learned from also some of the mistakes we've made and the ways that we've kind of made the trio as healthy as possible. And I want to kind of share what those are with you guys who are in a friendship trio and wanting to make sure that like you've still got your friends in five years or that you guys don't have some like awful heinous friendship breakup. So my first tip or way that I think friendship trio's work is
有趣的、充实的三人友谊中。我已经维持了将近四年。所以我愿意相信这是可能的。但我认为它有效的部分原因归结于这段友谊的运作方式，以及我从我们犯过的一些错误中吸取的教训，以及我们让这个三人组尽可能健康的方式。我想和你们这些身处三人友谊中并希望确保五年后你们依然拥有朋友，或者你们不会经历可怕的、令人发指的友谊破裂的人分享这些。所以我的第一个建议或我认为三人友谊有效的方法是
when you are able to acknowledge that sometimes you are just going to be jealous and sometimes what's worse is that jealousy is maybe going to be justified. A healthy trio is not one where nobody ever feels left out. You know, hopefully you feel that way 95% of the time, but there are going to be times where it's just unavoidable, even if it is not true, somebody might just perceive that they are being left out or that they weren't invited or that there was some hidden conversation happening, even if it's not true. And a healthy trio is one where those feelings are survivable because you, A, feel a deep sense of trust in the other people that they're not doing that to you.
当你能够承认，有时候你就是会感到嫉妒，而更糟糕的是，这种嫉妒有时或许是合情合理的。一个健康的铁三角并不是指里面没有任何一个人会感到被冷落。你知道的，希望你在95%的时间里都不会有这种感觉，但总会有些时候这是无可避免的；哪怕事实并非如此，也可能会有人只是觉得、察觉到自己被冷落了、没有被邀请，或者有什么私下里的秘密对话，即便根本没有这回事。而一个健康的铁三角，是能够挺过这些负面情绪的，因为第一，你对其他人有着深深的信任，坚信他们并不是故意那样对你的。
And B, because you maintain direct communication rather than simply relying on the mediator to manage communication. to manage communication, or rather than just not saying anything at all and expecting it to be okay and for somebody to read your mind. You know what I think is a huge sign of true emotional maturity and frontal lobe development? Especially in our 20s. It is not being afraid of conflict because you know that avoiding it hurts everybody more from a practical level. maybe you've even learnt that lesson the hard way a few times. One of the easiest traps that trios slide into is that they have side conversations rather than shared ones. It definitely feels safer in the moment to be like, oh my God, this person is really annoying me.
第二，因为你们会保持直接的沟通，而不是单纯依赖调解员来居中传话，或者什么都不说，却指望一切都会好起来，指望别人能读懂你的心思。你知道我认为什么是真正的情感成熟和前额叶皮层发育完全的巨大标志吗？特别是在我们20多岁的时候。那就是不惧怕冲突，因为你知道从现实层面来看，回避冲突只会对每个人造成更大的伤害。也许你甚至已经通过几次惨痛的教训明白了这一点。三人行最容易陷入的陷阱之一，就是私下各说各话，而不是开诚布公地共同交流。在当下，说一句“天哪，这个人真让我心烦”或者“她做那个事的时候真的把我气死”，这种感觉确实让人觉得更安全。
She really pissed me off when she did that. But over time, little alliances do start to form. People start second guessing what's being said about them when they're not there. You start to think, like, if I'm having to have. those conversations with that person, they're probably having those conversations about me. And so there's like this low level paranoia. Basically what we are describing here is the stage right before resentment. And we know from many key leading relationship institutes and experts that resentment erodes
但久而久之，小团体就开始形成了。人们开始猜测当自己不在场时，别人都在背后议论自己什么。你会开始想：如果我不得不和那个人那样背地里议论别人，那他们在背后肯定也是这么议论我的。于是，这种低级别的偏执情绪就产生了。基本上，我们在这里描述的就是怨恨产生前的那一个阶段。而从许多主要的亲密关系研究机构和专家的研究中我们都知道，怨恨对关系的侵蚀速度，
relationships faster than probably nothing else. whatever your impulse is to shove it down, to ignore it, you have to fight against that impulse. You have to swallow your pride and you have to say something because two options come out of that. A, you get through it unharmed, you patch it up, you understand each other better now. You, I really don't think you know somebody, especially a friend, until you've had a first fight. And so it's kind of a rite of passage. You guys get through it and it's amazing. or B, you say something and you realize like this person was never going to be able to survive
可能比其他任何东西都要快。无论你心里的冲动是把情绪强压下去还是选择忽视，你都必须与这种冲动做抗争。你必须放下自尊，必须把话说出来，因为这样做会有两种结果。第一，你们安然度过危机，重修旧好，并且现在能更好地理解彼此了。说实话，我真的觉得，一个人如果不和朋友经历一次大吵，就根本算不上真正了解对方。所以这其实是一种成长的洗礼。你们一起度过了难关，而且感觉好极了。或者第二，你把话说出来了，然后意识到：这个人根本没办法陪我一起
tough times with me. Anyways. And I can stop tiptoeing. Like, this was never going to work because here is this opportunity we have to work through it. And they're not taking it. So I think if nothing else, and this is going to sound so barbaric, but if nothing else, it's efficient. It's just purely efficient to talk to people about your problems. Okay, so we are going to take one more short break here before.
共度难关。总之，我不用再小心翼翼地看别人脸色了。这段关系本来就是行不通的，因为当我们需要一起解决问题时，对方根本不配合。所以我想，退一步讲——这听起来可能有点野蛮——但退一步讲，这样做效率很高。和别人坦诚沟通你的问题，纯粹就是高效率的做法。好了，在接下来的内容之前，我们先插播最后一个简短的广告。
before we get into my final three tips for maintaining friendship trios. The next one, by the way, is probably the most important of the more. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world.
在我们讲维持三人友谊的最后三个技巧之前。顺便说一句，接下来的这个技巧可能是这几个里面最重要的。所以请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健身以及在这个奇特现代世界中构建心理韧性的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，带你穿透那些主导养生行业、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
节目名称是拼写的 T-W-O-Persent，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。玩这种愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的下场。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在全新一季的《闺蜜》中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎根本不在乎。
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever. you got your podcast.
所以她们决定自己动手解决问题。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他一定会得到他应得的下场。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。
Remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush
还记得黛安·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍了两下莉儿·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什
got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense
跟莉儿·金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着去理解
of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一期节目中，马克·拉蒙特·hill大谈80年代的快克可卡因。说清楚点，对我和而言，84年意义重大，仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，不过先让大家知道这一点。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我的意思是，马克，说到这里，这已经是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿的主线了。我们现在甚至连艾滋病也摆到台面上来聊了。谢谢你帮我把话说完。我不认为对黑人来说，还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的全新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯。借着心理健康意识月的契机，我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的深度对话。我说的嘉宾有特里普·方丹、莱恩·克拉克。有时候，当我们执着于追求某样东西时，我们会被追逐的过程深深裹挟，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在盯着积分榜。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway. hard way and listen now.
我希望你们能真正地做一个好人。加入我卡尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的全新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力与人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the Hard Way。字面是 hard way，现在就来收听吧。
The next tip I have that I really recommend for flourishing friendship trios. It's like a tongue twister. Flourishing friendship trios, that's not that bad. It's allowing the central or core person to change over time. Trioes are naturally dynamic. We've talked about these roles. There will be phases when one person is more central, whether that is because they are, I don't know, going through a break.
我给出的下一个建议，是我极力推荐用来维持蓬勃发展的友谊铁三角的。这听起来像个绕口令。蓬勃发展的友谊铁三角，其实也没那么难。那就是允许核心人物随着时间推移而发生改变。铁三角关系天生就是动态的。我们讨论过这些角色。总会有这样的阶段：某个人会变得更加核心，无论是因为她们，我不知道，正经历分手中，
up or because they're, you know, the ones who are organizing everything or, I don't know, like, maybe they're, like, they're getting married or the ones with, like, the most energy at the time. Transitioning this over time and letting people flow into different roles and flow into, like, different seasons and be the one that takes on more and be the one that takes on less, I think prevents the resentment creeping in when you feel like you always have to show up in a certain way. If you feel like this is kind of weird and you're like, wait, things are changing. Wait, this person isn't making as many plans, like blah, blah, blah. Maybe it is your time to step into that role yourself.
还是因为她们，你知道的，是那个在操办一切的人，或者，我不知道，也许她们，比如，她们要结婚了，又或者她们是当时精力最充沛的人。随着时间推移让这种关系流动起来，允许人们转换到不同的角色中，顺应不同的时期，有时多承担一些，有时少承担一些，我认为这可以防止怨恨情绪悄悄滋生——当你觉得你总是必须要以某种特定方式表现自己时。如果你觉得这有点怪异，并且心想：等等，事情正在发生变化。等等，这个人不像以前那样热衷于做计划了，诸如此类。也许，这就是你挺身而出、自己扮演那个角色的时机。
It is easy to see change as this thing that is like life-ending threatening is going to ruin the friendship. but if nothing major or dramatic has happened, it may be that you're just resettling into a new way of relating to each other or just your new roles. So accept that change in your friendship is going to happen and just see how things fit. It's like romantic relationships. People need to take turns being different versions of themselves in the relationship.
人们很容易把改变看作是一件会毁灭友谊、如同世界末日般具有威胁性的事。但如果没有发生什么重大或戏剧性的事情，那可能只是意味着你们正在重新适应一种彼此相处的新方式，或者只是适应了你们各自的新角色。所以，请接受你们的友谊会发生改变这一事实，然后看看大家是如何契合彼此的。这就像浪漫关系一样。人们在关系中需要轮流展现不同版本的自己。
It is super normal. So you have to accept that, just like you have to accept jealousy. My third tip might sound a little bit counterintuitive at first, but I cannot also stress the importance enough of investing in the individual friendships first. You might hear me say that and be like, wait, hold up. Aren't we talking about how friendship trios always collapse because people feel left out? Yes, sometimes, but if we think back to the concept of similian ties, the trio was built on three strong connections plus the fourth big one.
这超级正常。所以你必须接受这一点，就像你必须接受嫉妒一样。我的第三个建议乍一看可能有点违反直觉，但我怎么强调分别经营个体友谊的重要性都不为过。你听到我这么说可能会想：等等，等一下。我们不是在讨论为什么友谊铁三角总会因为有人感到被冷落而崩溃吗？是的，有时候会这样，但如果我们回想一下西美尔社会网（Simmelian ties）的概念，铁三角是由三个稳固的双人连接加上第四个大连接构建起来的。
If these individual connections aren't well maintained, if you and the other person separately don't know each other or aren't really hanging out with each other well enough, the trio is going to start to weaken simply because the ties that make it up are weak as well. obviously don't take a private bloody trip to new york and not tell the other person because that's insane but like go and grab coffee just with one friend sometimes or go for long walks just with the other friend it also stops you from becoming dependent on one person to carry the dynamic if you're close to both people in the group then this is good practice it's not weird it shouldn't be uncomfortable when one of you isn't available or when one of you just wants to do something with
如果这些个体连接没有得到很好的维护，如果你和另一个人单独相处时并不真正了解对方，或者没有足够好地一起出去玩，那么铁三角关系就会开始削弱，仅仅是因为构成它的纽带本身也变弱了。当然，别自顾自地偷偷跑去纽约旅行却不告诉另一个人，因为那太疯狂了；但你可以偶尔只和其中一个朋友去喝杯咖啡，或者只和另一个朋友去散散步。这样做也能防止你过度依赖某一个人来维系这种动态关系。如果你和群里的两边关系都很亲密，这就是很好的实践，这并不奇怪，当你们其中一人没空，或者其中一人只想和另一个人做点什么的时候，这本就不该让人感到不舒服。
the other person. What it does mean though is that you've also, you've got to be okay with your friends doing stuff without you from time to time. Because back to that big T word, like you trust that you also have spaces where you are central to and each relationship is equally as strong as the next one. Really, like it's a trust exercise. We're coming back to this again and again. And at the end of the day, you have to know in your deepest of hearts that these people love you, they're not going to leave you out. Your friendship can survive change. Now, to wrap up this episode, let's return to the dilemma at the beginning. And what happens if none of this is working, your friendship is just falling apart, it is in like a tailspin, like it is going down.
不过，这意味着你必须习惯你的朋友们有时会不带你一起玩。因为回到那个重要的T开头词汇——信任，你要相信，你也有属于自己的、你是核心的社交空间，并且每一段关系都与其他关系同样牢固。说真的，这就像是一场信任练习。我们一直在反复强调这一点。到头来，你必须在内心深处明白，这些人是爱你的，她们不会把你排除在外。你们的友谊能够经受住改变的考验。好了，作为本集节目的尾声，让我们回到开头的那个两难困境。如果这一切都无济于事，你们的友谊正在分崩离析，正处于失控的螺旋式下降中，就像飞机坠毁一样。
What do we do then? What do we do and we're unsure if we want to continue the friendship trio or the friendship singular? My advice is for this person again, but also for all situations like this in general. When you find yourself in a dynamic like this where something has happened, a situation has occurred, please talk about it as quickly as possible. Do not ignore that advice. Do not let an emotional wound fester. If it has gotten to that point where like you guys are at a stalemate,
那我们该怎么办？当我们不确定是想维持这个铁三角关系还是单独维持某段友谊时，我们该怎么办？我的建议既针对这个人，也适用于所有类似的一般情况。当你发现自己陷入这样一种动态中：某事已经发生，某种状况已经出现，请尽快谈一谈。千万不要忽视这个建议。不要让情感伤口溃烂。如果事情已经发展到你们陷入僵局的地步，
be the bigger person and reach out. and I know you probably don't want to hear that. You probably hate hearing that. But really the question is this. Is this friendship worth it to you? Is it worth saving? How long have you been friends? Have you made similar mistakes in the past and been forgiven?
那就拿出成熟的姿态，主动联系对方。我知道你可能不想听到这样的话。你可能讨厌听到这话。但真正的问题其实是：这段友谊对你来说有价值吗？它值得挽救吗？你们做朋友多久了？过去你犯过类似的错误并被原谅过吗？
Is this something I think that we can recover from? It doesn't have to be a mutual decision. But if you decide, like, hey, yeah, I actually love this person. I'm going to regret not trying to fix this. I care about them, enough to do the hard thing. You've got to follow that instinct and you've got to do it. Prepare to be honest. Go in it with like your heart on your sleeve.
这会是我们能够恢复的事情吗？这不一定非得是一个共同决定的结果。但如果你决定：嘿，是的，我其实很在乎这个人。如果我不去尝试修复它，我会后悔的。我在乎她们，足够让我去克服困难。你必须顺从这种直觉，并且付诸行动。准备好坦诚相待。带着你的真心去沟通。
But I think you cannot fix and you cannot get out of this if things aren't in the open. You need to seriously be like, this sucked and I'm really upset. And I'm going to let you guys also deal with the consequences of your action through my emotions. I do want some kind of apology. I do want some kind of acknowledgement, but it doesn't mean that we can't get over this. Everybody in this situation, and I think this is what friendship trues, and friendships in general, every single one of them will require this at some point. Somebody needs to swallow their pride.
但我认为，如果不把事情摊开来讲，你是无法修复、无法摆脱这种困境的。你需要严肃地表达：这真的很糟糕，我非常难过。而且我要让你们也通过我的情绪来承担你们行为的后果。我的确想要某种道歉。我的确想要某种认可，但这并不意味着我们无法跨过这个坎。在这类情况中的每个人——我想这也是友谊铁三角以及普通友谊所面临的共同点——每一个友谊在某个时刻都需要经历这一点。总得有人放下自尊。
And if they do acknowledge it and they sincerely apologize, don't forget them straight away. Go away for a few days. See how you feel. Has that apology helped? What kind of changes are you expecting? What is going to be the line you don't want? crossed and move on from there. If they don't apologize, if the radio silence continues, if they don't take accountability, I'm sorry, but I just don't think it's in your hands anymore.
如果她们确实承认了错误并且真诚地道歉了，不要马上就原谅她们。先离开几天。看看你的感觉如何。那个道歉起作用了吗？你期待什么样的改变？你不想触碰的底线是什么？然后从那里继续前进。如果她们不道歉，如果冷战仍在继续，如果她们不承担责任，很抱歉，但我认为这已经不在你的掌控之中了。
And I think that's nice that you know you tried. You were the one who was the bigger person. Maybe you just need to let the friendship rest for a bit. Nobody else can draw that line for you, but I think some red flags that often signal that the trio is doing more harm than good are when you do feel chronically left out. You do feel really anxious rather than excited or happy before seeing them. After spending time together as well, you know, you regularly leave feeling smaller than when you arrived. You feel ganged up on, you feel belittled, you feel isolated. you might also feel kind of ashamed or overstimulated.
而我觉得，至少你知道自己努力过了，这就很好了。你是那个表现得更成熟的人。也许你只需要让这段友谊暂时沉淀一下。没有人能为你划定这条界限，但我认为，一些通常预示着铁三角关系弊大于利的红旗信号包括：当你确实感到长期被冷落；在见她们之前，你感到的不是兴奋或快乐，而是真正的焦虑；在花时间相处之后，你知道，离开时你常常觉得自己比来时更加渺小；你觉得自己被群殴了、被贬低了、被孤立了。你可能还会感到某种羞耻或过度刺激。
Like you really have to put a lot of energy into this rather than just seeing your friends. And I think the biggest sign that the friendship is done is when you just don't like who you are when you shop with the group. Maybe because it is making you feel defensive or jealous or needy. I think a lot of this is because often when we know, something is wrong, we can sense it. When we know people are trying to exclude us, we can sense it. And so we become very hypervigilant out of fear. And that just makes us feel all these kinds of really irritated emotions to do with the friendship trio that just like bleeds in and destroys everything. If this friendship is making you feel exhausted rather than lighter, it's simply not worth it.
就像你必须在这上面投入大量精力，而不是单纯去见朋友。而且我认为友谊结束的最大标志是，当你甚至不喜欢自己和这个群体在一起时的样子。也许是因为这让你感到防御、嫉妒或需求过度。我想这很大程度上是因为，通常当我们明知有什么不对劲时，我们是能感觉得到的。当我们知道有人试图排挤我们时，我们是能感觉到的。于是出于恐惧，我们变得高度警惕。而这只会让我们对这个友谊铁三角产生种种烦躁的情绪，这些情绪会渗透进来并摧毁一切。如果这段友谊让你感到筋疲力尽，而不是轻松自在，那它就根本不值得。
And there will be more people out there who value you and value your time and will be receptive to you now that you have more time for them rather than for these people that might not care about you. The practical side of leaving can be really difficult. You know, you often feel like you're losing two friendships at once plus the friendship of the three of you. And I feel for you and I'm really sorry. It doesn't mean the door is closed forever. What I would say is if you find yourself in this situation, try not to ghost. Don't just disappear and stop replying to your friends. Like it sounds like our listeners friends are doing to her. I know that that might be tempting,
外面会有更多懂你、珍惜你的时间、并且会对你做出回应的人，既然你现在有了更多时间留给他们，而不是留给那些可能根本不在乎你的人。抽身离去的实际层面可能会非常困难。你知道，你常常会觉得你一下子失去了两段友谊，外加你们三个人的集体友谊。我能对你感同身受，我也深表遗憾。但这并不意味着大门永远关闭。我想说的是，如果你发现自己陷入这种境遇，尽量不要玩人间蒸发。不要突然消失并不再回复朋友的信息。就像听众的朋友们对她做的那样。我知道这可能很诱人，
and I think throughout this conversation, there's been obvious easy routes that we can take, but you don't want to give people ammunition to say that you didn't try or say that it was your fault. You don't want to give people ammunition to justify shitty behavior. The best you can do now is focus on leaving with the knowledge. I did what I could. I tried.
而且我想在整个谈话过程中，我们都有显而易见、轻而易举的捷径可走，但你不想给别人留下攻击你的口实，让别人说你没有努力，或者说这都是你的错。你不想给别人提供为糟糕行为辩护的弹药。你现在能做的最好的事情，就是带着“我尽力了，我尝试过了”的认知坦然离开。
There are no good and bad guys, But I'm definitely trying my hardest to be good in the situation to the people I love. Don't be too hard on yourself. Like, again, you did your best. I will also say this. One final word of advice. Their decisions and their actions will not be without remorse. If you've found a deeply important friendship trio are otherwise exploding,
这里没有绝对的好人和坏人，但我绝对在努力在这个处境中对我爱的人做一个好人。不要对自己太苛刻。同样，你已经尽力了。我还要说最后一点。最后一条建议。她们的决定和行为绝不会没有愧疚感。如果你发现一段至关重要的友谊铁三角最终破裂了，
like not to sound threatening, but they will regret it. They will someday in the future they are going to think about you, and they're going to think about the memories you're like you're probably contemplating as well right now and they're going to say to themselves like oh my god I really miss that person I think I really screwed that up sometimes what makes these situations harder is because we start to drive ourselves crazy thinking like did they ever even care about me did I waste all this time kind of like we do with an ex and they do and they did and they will continue to care about you it's up to you whether you want to leave the door open? I think that you should. I think there's always chances for redemption in,
这听起来可能不是威胁，但她们会后悔的。总有一天在未来，她们会想起你，会想起你们共同的回忆——就像你现在可能也在脑海中回味的一样，她们会对自己说：天哪，我真的很想念那个人，我觉得我把事情彻底搞砸了。有时候，让这些情况变得更难处理的原因是，我们会开始把自己逼疯，去想：她们到底有没有在乎过我？我是不是白白浪费了这么多时间？就像我们对待前任那样。而她们确实在乎，她们过去在乎，将来也会继续在乎你。至于你想不想给这段关系留一线生机，全凭你个人的意愿。我认为你应该这么做。我认为总有重修旧好的机会，
even if it's not tomorrow, if it's in 10 years, or at least for reminiscing. So I hope you enjoyed this episode. I hope that it was informative and is helping you if you're in a hard time or situation like this. Our question for today, if you have made it this far, thank you for listening. Thank you for being a loyal listener. In the comments below, what is your favorite depiction of good friendship in a movie or TV show. I'll go first. Mine is Goodwill Hunting. For sure, all-time favorite movie depicting friendship. But drop yours below. Make sure you are also following us on Instagram or wherever you are listening. If you're subscribed, that's amazing. If you're not, what are you doing? Give us a five-star review if you feel cool to do so. And thank you, as always,
即使不是明天，如果是十年后呢，至少还可以用来缅怀。希望你喜欢这期节目。希望它能给你带来启发，并在你处于这样艰难的时期或处境时对你有所帮助。我们今天的问题是，如果你听到了这里，谢谢你的收听。谢谢你成为我们忠实的听众。在下方的评论区里，你最喜欢的电影或电视剧中对美好友谊的描绘是什么？我先来。我最喜欢的是《心灵捕手》。绝对是史上最棒的描绘友谊的电影。把你的答案留在下方吧。请确保同时在 Instagram 或你收听节目的任何平台上关注我们。如果你已经订阅了，那太棒了。如果没有，你在等什么呢？如果你觉得有必要，请给我们一个五星好评。一如既往地感谢
to our researcher Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode. She is marvelous. I don't know what we would do without her. Until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way
我们的研究员利比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本期节目的贡献。她太棒了。我真不知道没有她我们该怎么办。下次见之前，保重身体。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，
with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人卡尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人随身穿着一身精神铠甲？它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。
Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健身以及在这个奇特现代世界中构建心理韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。节目名称是拼写的 TWO%。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己动手解决问题。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逍遥法外的。他一定会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和而言是个大日子。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
与我们的朋友、同仁喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那是个疯狂的年份。我不认为对黑人来说，还有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。